♪ T-SERIES!
(YEAH!) ♪
♪ IT'S YOUR BIG DAY!
(WOO!) ♪
♪ INCREDIBLE JOB! ♪
♪ I KNOW WE HAD OUR DIFFERENCES ♪
♪ BUT TODAY,
I JUST WANNA TELL YOU ♪
♪ A CONGRATULATIONS (UH),
IT'S A CELEBRATION ♪
♪ PARTY ALL DAY, I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WAITIN' (HERE WE GO!) ♪
♪ A CONGRATULATIONS (WOO!),
IT'S A CELEBRATION ♪
♪ I JUST WANNA TELL YOU THAT
I THINK THAT YOU'RE AMAZING ♪
♪ A CONGRATULATIONS
TO YOUR CORPORATION ♪
♪ GUESS TO BEAT ONE SWEDISH
BOY, YOU NEED A BILLION ASIANS ♪
♪ YEAH, YOU DID IT VERY NICE,
AND ALL IT TOOK ♪
♪ WAS A MASSIVE CORPORATE ENTITY
WITH EVERY SONG IN BOLLYWOOD ♪
♪ NOW YOU'RE AT NUMBER ONE (ONE),
HOPE YOU DID NOTHING WRONG ♪
♪ LIKE STARTING YOUR BUSINESS
BY SELLING PIRATED SONGS ♪
♪ OOPS! DIDN'T THINK WE'D SEE?
IT'S RIGHT THERE ON WIKIPEDIA ♪
♪ GET USED TO YOUR PAST BEING HELD
AGAINST YOU BY THE MEDIA (UH-OH) ♪
♪ I'M SURE RIGHT NOW THERE'S NOTHING
THAT YOU'RE DOING THAT'S ILLEGAL, YEAH ♪
♪ I'M CERTAIN THAT YOU HAVEN'T
HAD COLLUSIONS WITH THE MAFIA ♪
♪ FOR LEGAL REASONS, THAT'S A JOKE ♪
♪ FOR SERIOUS, INDIAN MAFIA,
PLEASE DON'T KILL ME, THAT'S A JOKE ♪
♪ INDIA, I'M SORRY ABOUT THE
MEMES, YOU'RE THE BEST ♪
♪ I LOVE MY INDIAN BROS,
FROM BOMBAY TO BANGLADESH ♪
♪ I'LL TAKE ON ALL THE WORLD
FOR YOU, I'M A HEAVY HITTER ♪
♪ 'BOUT TO CAUSE A GENOCIDE
SO YOU CAN CALL ME HI— ♪
♪ A CONGRATULATIONS,
IT'S A CELEBRATION (OH!) ♪
♪ PARTY ALL DAY, I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WAITIN' (OH YEAH!) ♪
♪ A CONGRATULATIONS (WOO!),
IT'S A CELEBRATION (YEAH!) ♪
♪ I JUST WANNA TELL YOU THAT
I THINK THAT YOU'RE AMAZING ♪
♪ CONGRATULATIONS
(UH) ♪
(IT'S YOUR BIG DAY!) ♪
♪ CONGRATULATIONS
(WOO!) ♪
(SUCH A BIG DAY!) ♪
♪ I GOT A LETTER IN THE POST,
HMM, WHAT IS THIS? (HMM) ♪
♪ T-SERIES SAYING
"CEASE AND DESIST" ♪
♪ HAD A PROBLEM WITH ME TELLING
THEM TO HOLD THEIR DEFECATION ♪
♪ BUT, LET ME EDUCATE YOU, SILLY,
THAT'S NOT DEFAMATION (WOO) ♪
♪ T-SERIES CAN EAT A DICK
(STILL NOT DEFAMATION) ♪
♪ SUCK MY FUCKING SWEDISH MEATBALLS
(STILL NOT DEFAMATION, YUM) ♪
♪ DID YOU KNOW THAT INDIANS
HAVE POO-POO IN THEIR BRAINS? ♪
♪ THAT'S A BLATANT RACIST LIE ♪
♪ YEAH, BUT STILL NOT DEFAMATION!
(WOO) ♪
♪ INDIA GOT YOUTUBE FIGURED OUT,
THAT'S SICK, SON ♪
♪ HOW 'BOUT NEXT YOU FIGURE HOW
TO FIX THE CASTE SYSTEM? (OOF) ♪
♪ MAYBE ALL THOSE ADS WILL
SOLVE YOUR CRIPPLING POVERTY ♪
♪ BUT LOOKING AT T-SERIES' PAST,
I'M GUESSING NOT PROBABLY ♪
♪ BUT NEVER MIND THE POOR
PEOPLE, WE JUST HERE TO PARTY ♪
♪ JUST HERE TO POP SOME BOTTLES
WITH THE NINE-YEAR-OLD ARMY ♪
♪ NON-ALCOHOLIC 'CAUSE
I HAD A REAL PROBLEM ♪
♪ BUT WE STILL OUT HERE LIVING
LIKE WE 'BOUT TO KAMIKAZE ♪
♪ SO THIS IS IT, THANKS FOR
STICKING WITH MY CHANNEL ♪
♪ EVER SINCE I WAS A NOBODY,
SCREAMING AT BARRELS ♪
♪ YEAH, THIS IS IT, IT'S
BEEN AN ADVENTURE ♪
♪ IT'S THE END OF THE REIGN OF
"FELIX ARVID ULF KJELLBERG" ♪
♪ THROUGH ALL THE CHANGE AND
CONTROVERSY, YOU'VE BEEN BY MY SIDE ♪
♪ THERE'S NO ARMY IN THE WORLD,
I WOULD RATHER GIVE ME WATCH TIME ♪
♪ IT'S BEEN A WILD RIDE,
SO WHILE I CAN STILL BE HEARD ♪
♪ HERE'S ONE LAST BROFIST
FROM THE NUMBER ONE IN THE WORLD ♪
♪ A CONGRATULATIONS,
IT'S A CELEBRATION (OH) ♪
♪ PARTY ALL DAY (SKRAA), I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WAITIN' (YEET, PARTY ALL DAY, YEAH) ♪
♪ A CONGRATULATIONS (WOO!),
IT'S A CELEBRATION (OH) ♪
♪ I JUST WANNA TELL YOU THAT
I THINK THAT YOU'RE AMAZING ♪
♪ CONGRATULATIONS
(OH, OOH-HOO) ♪
(SKRATTAR DU, IT'S YOUR BIG DAY!) ♪
♪ CONGRATULATIONS
(I'M FUCKING LIT!) ♪
(SUCH A BIG DAY! OH YEAH, YEAH) ♪
♪ CONGRATULATIONS, T-SERIES! ♪
♪ YOU DID IT! ♪
♪ YATTA DESU NE ♪
♪ HOPE THAT #METOO STUFF DOESN'T
SEVERELY AFFECT YOUR BOTTOM LINE ♪
(WHEEZING)
(SOMEONE'S CLAPPING)
(MR. BEAST'S CLAPPING)